Je suis Gerardo Je joue des marques J'ai 35 ans
je suis président du parlement pas dans le
Vénézuélien et président en charge de
Venezuela par l'article 233 de notre
Constitution
beaucoup de gens dans le monde n'ont pas
en tant que pays que j'ai en tant que Venezuela
a pu atteindre
à ce niveau à ce point ce qui est
qui se passe dans ce pays avec les réserves
les plus grandes compagnies pétrolières du monde
avait l'un des meilleurs pib de la planète
aussi outil de développement
malheureusement l'éducation sociale aujourd'hui
produit de la corruption pendant de nombreuses années
du vol entre 300 000 et 400 000
millions de dollars de fonds publics et
incapacité un modèle mal implémenté
que nous avons malheureusement régressé
qu'aujourd'hui 25 % de la population
cette urgence humanitaire complexe de
quatre millions de Vénézuéliens ont
migré de 15% et celui de
continuer le flow mon autre cette année
nous courons le risque de surmonter
même la syrie figure dans la migration
bien et comment pouvez-vous être président
s'il y a encore un président de ligne
fleurs nicholas mûrissent la période
modèle présidentiel expiré le 10
janvier 2019 il n'y a pas eu d'élection
valable en 2018 le cas échéant
par la constitution pour laquelle le
président du parlement national en
ce cas, j'élis par les voix du
2015 et élu par moi par les députés
en tant que président du parlement
correspond selon l'article 233 du
notre constitution sera le président
commandé dans le sera de réaliser un
libre choix dans notre pays
à ceux qui disent que Nicolás Maduro est
président toujours parce qu'il a le
début de la force armée bien que
les matures leur répondraient non pour se voir
comme président mais comme dictateur
sa période constitutionnelle a expiré et
la force kidnappe
les pouvoirs de l'état
mais il reste encore une partie
population vénézuélienne qui soutient tout
thème taureau dans quelle mesure êtes-vous un
président légitime pour eux bon
Selon la dernière étude d'analyse de données
90% de la population soutient un
changer et seulement moins de 10%
Aujourd'hui, ils soutiennent Nicolás Maduro Moors dans
certainement un choix vraiment libre
qui est ce qui par constitution est mon
mandat de président par intérim
déterminer qui devrait gouverner le venezuela
mais par constitution il est le président
du parlement dans ce cas moi qui
doit réaliser ce libre choix
et tu as parlé dernièrement avec
Nicolás Maduro ne
jamais non seulement en 2016 quand c'était
au parlement et à l'époque il était
il a dit qu'il devrait libérer les prisonniers
politiciens au venezuela déjà à cette époque
il y avait plus de 400 prisonniers politiques
Venezuela
maintenant que s'est-il passé le 30 avril qu'est-ce que c'était
le but de l'opération liberté a
transition démocratique au venezuela
ils ont produit l'action vraiment libre de
nouveau par constitution ce que je
correspond est de stabiliser l'urgence
s'en occuper et être capable d'arrêter une alimentation
catastrophe pour pouvoir avoir une action
vraiment gratuit au venezuela et réseau et re
guider le pays avec le problème rétro
devant le monde un pays avec de vastes
réserves naturelles à la prospérité de
nouveau aujourd'hui 7 millions de Vénézuéliens
sont en danger de mort par
la décision unitaire garde la parole
complexe signifie qu'il n'a pas été causé
cette urgence pour un tremblement de terre pour un
tornade ou par quelque chose de naturel mais c'était par
incapacité corruption et en raison de
humain le 30 avril a manifesté le
le mécontentement des forces armées
il l'a fait en cúcuta les militaires n'ont pas
les sergents listés ont fait un
secteur très prisé de Caracas il y a 1 mois
En fin de compte, le mécontentement des
forces armées dans ce qui se passe
au Vénézuela
mais que s'est-il passé précisément le 30 et
d'apprentissage se manifeste rapidement
militaire contre mature inclus
au général de division
christopher figuera exigeant quoi
J'ai besoin que nous fassions tout
Gouvernement vénézuélien sur la situation sanitaire
de la transition et des élections libres
fonctionne à 100% le fonctionnement est bon
évident qu'aujourd'hui Maduro continue d'usurper
fonctionne à miraflores mais s'ils savent
quel pourcentage a fonctionné aujourd'hui ils ont
beaucoup moins de soutien non seulement dans le
rues mais aussi dans les forces
armé
après 20 ans d'horaire
polarisation au venezuela vous n'avez pas
estime que les Vénézuéliens sont fatigués
écouter les promesses qui concrètement
les baisers n'étaient pas faits, ils ne sont pas
fatigué si proche de la mort
Je pense que c'est beaucoup plus grave ou devrais-je
insister 40% de la population 25
émergeant sa mesure complexe 15 par
cent qui ont même émigré
à pied de Caracas, nous faisons le
entretien au pérou
il y a des milliers de kilomètres de routes
état de désespoir qu'une personne doit avoir
personne à marcher des milliers de kilomètres
fuyant l'armée sont fatigués de
promesses à risque de mort produit de
politiques irresponsables de 20 ans de
corruption et que nous avons la possibilité
Vénézuéliens de la grande opportunité
malgré cette dictature malgré
cette persécution malgré la torture
qu'ils aient reçu que nous ayons reçu
les chefs de l'opposition obtiennent
liberté et démocratie notre pays
et tu ne crois pas ce qui s'est passé le 30
April a découragé une partie des
l'opposition mais que le 30 avril est un
reflet de la société et de ce qui se passe
dans les forces armées aussi certains
nous avons besoin de plus que de membre
de la force armée commune aux
côté constitution
aujourd'hui certains Vénézuéliens sont
Fatigués de la crise ils n'en peuvent plus
cette crise et ne voient pas d'autre solution que
une intervention militaire américaine
aimerions être en faveur non seulement avons-nous
alternatives pour construire une solution
nous politique une solution que nous
conduire à la stabilité
gouvernance et libre choix oui
le moindre coût social où l'on dit
ils sont fatigués bien sûr car il en a cinq
mois sans eau dans ton cas tu n'en as pas assez
nourrir votre enfant quand vous n'avez pas
comment se rendre à votre travail
les transports en commun lorsque le
léger comme le cas de l'état de Zulia
à maracaibo par exemple ça arrive trois
heures par jour l'électricité que nous avons
état seulement cet état a produit un
millions trois cent mille barils de
huile par jour
image de ce que cela signifie pour un
économie cette quantité a aujourd'hui trois
heures d'électricité par jour deviennent si
fatigué il pensait qu'on devait exister quoi
nous avons traversé une situation angoissante dans un
la catastrophe que vit la société aujourd'hui
venezuela mais malgré cela nous sommes
la plupart d'entre nous font les rues plus
étaient chacun des secteurs de
venezuela nous avons formé la coalition
de tout le pays aussi le soutien
international aussi le mécontentement des
une force armée aussi la distribution
diplomate afin que cette option
celui qui est le meilleur dans celui qui est le plus rapide
qui limite le coût social et génère
gouvernance et stabilité
nous ne sommes pas amoureux d'un mécanisme
notre réalisation est entre les mains de
Le Venezuela pour pouvoir le transformer
mais l'intervention militaire
L'américain est une option que vous
nie
aujourd'hui quand entre 2017 et 2000 sont morts
20 000 enfants regardent ccoo et sous un
année en raison de la malnutrition 20 000 sont vus
nourrissons de moins d'un an sur deux et
moins deux ans faute de nourriture
nous sommes avec tous
des outils pour arriver au sevrage
situation du gouvernement de transition et
élections libres argumentent bien sûr
entre un type d'action ne serait pas équitable
aujourd'hui pour les Vénézuéliens aujourd'hui le seul
pourcentage d'intervention qui existe dans
Le territoire vénézuélien est celui des militaires
ou intelligence d'animation et
contre-espionnage de la présidence
du ln à venise extrayant de l'or pour
financer un mouvement paramilitaire et
guérilla pour le président
parlement national que je représente
du venezuela demande coopération et
monde qui réalise la transition doit
donner dans les paramètres
urgence humanitaire pour protéger
citoyen pour assurer une transition
mensuel démocratique, vous pourriez
répondre spécifiquement en ce qui concerne
une intervention militaire américaine dans
Venezuela
quel serait le scénario idéal
vous passez du pouvoir à être
produire dans les plus brefs délais
vraiment libre choix ayant
récupéré les institutions dans ce
cas du conseil national l'arbitre qui
régit les élections au Venezuela et que
partie d'un absolument gratuit ne peut pas
être un dictateur exerçant des fonctions
cela signifie qu'une grande partie de
transition mais de pouvoir pour un
choix vraiment et ce qui est arrivé à la
l'aide humanitaire qui restait dans le
les frontières du venezuela entrait
pas dans les volumes nécessaires pour
contenir l'urgence 25% de la
population en urgence il y a tous
grands centres de collecte en cours
à cúcuta au brésil surtout le
la Croix Rouge
réussir à saisir une partie de cette aide
mais ce ne sera pas suffisant pour pouvoir
contenir l'urgence dont nous parlons
canal humanitaire auquel nous avons assisté
100 000 personnes en ce moment mais de
encore une fois si un millier de personnes est à seulement 3% de la
les personnes qui ont besoin de ces soins
et quelle solution proposez-vous pour
lutter contre le problème de la pauvreté
au venezuela une personne un immense pays
potentiel de génération de ressources de
travail
nous devons avoir des indices très élevés
inégalité bas donc il y avait il y avait
l'accès aux opportunités, mais nous devons
sauver l'industrie aussi sauver le
sécurité juridique de l'entreprise privée
aujourd'hui au venezuela ils ont un risque que vous
exproprier dans une entreprise que vous ne pouvez pas
être respecté votre esprit d'entreprise même
alors nous sommes à l'élémentaire
sécurité juridique sécurité personnelle
ouverture de la capacité d'investissement privé
reprise dans cette répression pétrolière
de la campagne agroalimentaire au venezuela
accès aux biens et services éducation des
qualité
un grand nombre de professionnels ont
J'ai visité le monde donc je pense
qu'il existe une formule parfaite pour
redresser le pays en surmontant la pauvreté et
ce ne sera plus un levier d'appui uniquement
mentionner mais pour la région et
quel est le plan spécifiquement pour
reconstruire le pays après comment vont-ils
être le thermos économique à combattre
contre l'inflation pour diversifier
L'économie cubaine que le Venezuela a en
ce cas le levier d'huile pour
pouvoir
réinvestir rapidement au venezuela
il faut réactiver l'appareil productif
A cette époque, c'était le centre de
grandes entreprises contre l'inflation
faut aussi trouver la dépense
seules les dépenses publiques sur les dépenses
procureur nous devons récupérer et encore
700 000 barils de plomb qui évoluent
pour 32 mille 948 et prenez-le ainsi que le 6
millions de barils de pétrole/jour
diversifier le pouvoir économique
réinvestir au venezuela et soutenir le
entreprise privée et comment vont-ils
sortir de la dépendance au pétrole
diversifier très facilement quand
en fait un levier de production
a d'énormes avantages comparatifs
parce que par situation géographique par
des plages pour la diversité et la biosphère même
nous pouvons convertir ces avantages
comparatif et compétitif dans les produits
important pour l'exportation de petites personnes
de nouveaux accès de sécurité personnelle dans le
le service c'est aussi l'industrie
l'exploitation minière en développement doit être commandée
exploitée sans discernement dans le sud de la
pays à travers l'arc minier aussi
nous avons la possibilité
encore une fois pour l'emplacement étant un passe-temps
important aéronautique nous avons le
possibilité aussi du vrai campus
heureusement illimité
la reconstruction économiquement nous ne le faisons pas
nous inquiète encore aujourd'hui
pénétration de lln le protégé était un
bras
du régime d'affinage dans
le trafic de drogue qui sont des choses que nous devons
surmonter rapidement et nous avons besoin de
force armée pour cette souveraineté sur
cela et prendre des mesures de sécurité
Nicolás Valieron soutient que vous ne
tu es un traître à la patrie parce que tu
est toujours libre parce que nous sommes pour
notre constitution d'abord parce que
Je suis présent le visage et la pression de
charge est de faire une constitution
article 233 à cause d'un grand soutien
populaire et largement reconnu
international mais ici vous ne pouvez pas
enregistrer où nous sommes il y a un danger non
pour savoir où nous sommes doit
se cacher dans la rue à cause de l'insécurité
en fait mais vous avez directement
oui cache je ne viens pas
en ce moment de valence d'un très marché
populaire
nous sommes dans l'arène dans
centre valencien le plus populaire de l'état
Carabobo j'ai un plan avantage
pays dont nous parlons en ce moment
notre bureau qu'est-ce que je vais faire dans
miraflores mais nous sommes dans une situation
de ses actions et de la dictature qui
nous allions en fait à une activité de rue
et quel est le plan maintenant et qu'est-ce qui va se passer
renforces-tu ce que nous sommes venus
Faire
penser qu'il n'y a pas de dictature
formule pour générer une transition
qu'il y a des éléments et des variables pour
contrôle ou variables à exercer
la plupart des pressions internationales
le contrôle des actifs nous permet d'être
heureusement l'argent des Vénézuéliens
parler le processus plus enlever le
soutien politique et nous sommes tous
faire de l'exercice si on compte chacun
une de ces variables il y a 34 plus poular
90% du pays s'effondre
la coalition dominante quand on parle
par exemple la loterie tous les jours quand le
de bouche rouge la chose normale est que c'est pour
figueres lorsque chacun des
militaire quand on parle de
à l'échelle internationale, nous avons vu
position non seulement du groupe de
l'animation ou aussi le groupe
contact international quand
nous parlons d'autres domaines fondamentaux
que dans notre constitution nous avons vu
et les députés du psoe ont rejoint
même
que devrions-nous faire toutes ces options
provoquer simultanément
transition conclusion quand nicolas
boulanger mature
bientôt en changement